do you know that two out of every three
guys are going to experience some form
about just by the time they're 35 I know
for me it was more like 25 look I wish
keeps have been around when I was
younger because advancements in science
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have you
can get an experts treatment plan
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or Pharmacy delivered directly to your
front door at about half the price of a
traditional Pharmacy yep keeps offers
clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
your hair growth and because it's a
simple subscription model their regular
refill reminders and fast shipping will
keep you stocked up on all the product
that you need to take care of your hair
how does it work well for one thing no
need to visit a doctor's office just
schedule a quick online consult and a
little bit later a discrete package will
arrive at your door and you can use it
in the comfort and privacy of your own
home each treatment comes with a year of
free messaging so you can connect with
your medical provider at any time hair
loss stops with keeps you guys can get
50 off your order by going to keep dot
com slash biographics that's keps.com
biographics or just click the link in
the description below to receive 50 off
your first order and now today's video
if you lived in Harlem during the 1970s
and you were looking for some dope there
was a multitude of options available to
you you had Mean Machine ding dong
Taster's Choice Harlem hijacked tragic
magic Rush official correct and that's
just the ones that we could say without
getting demonetized but none of them
compared to Blue Magic Frank Lucas's
product that was at least 10 Pure Heroin
when all his competitors only offered
five or even three percent Purity
according to the man himself at the
height of his power during the early
1970s his criminal Empire was spending
two hundred thousand dollars a week on
police bribes alone but that was nothing
since it raked in over a million dollars
a day in drug sales with over 300
million dollars worth of heroin
stockpiled in his secret stash Luca's
own property in New York Miami Los
Angeles Detroit Puerto Rico and North
Carolina and when he wasn't busy
spending Millions on cars clothes
jewelry or flying to Paris just for a
nice lunch he was Palling around with a
rich and famous like James Brown Joe
Lewis and Diana Ross in an interview he
gave in 2 1000 Frank Lucas said that he
always knew his life was a movie and he
was right seven years later his story
was up on the Silver Screen with Denzel
Washington playing him in the film
American Gangster which told the tale of
how Frank Lucas became one of the
biggest drug kingpings in the history of
New York City
[Music]
despite his strong association with
Harlem Frank Lucas was not a native New
Yorker he was actually born in Lagrange
North Carolina around September the 9th
1930 the oldest boy of Fred Lucas and
Markley Jones right off the bat we
should specify that Frank Lucas was a
man who let's just say had a peripheral
relationship with the truth nobody
thought that Frank Lucas was a badass
more than Frank Lucas himself he enjoyed
the sound of his own voice and gave
plenty of interviews later in life that
then formed the bases for the
biographies on him he even co-authored
his own self-aggrandizing autobiography
in 2010 which we used liberally for this
video but the veracity of many of his
statements and claims has fallen under a
cloud of skepticism and dubiousness
thought to put it plainly we're not sure
what actually happened and what Lucas
made up to make himself feel more
important a perfect example of this is
one of Young Frank's first formative
experiences the one which he claimed set
him on the path of a life of crime when
he was only six years old living out of
the sticks in North Carolina in a
rundown one-room Shack during the
greater Russian the family had Frank's
older cousin obadar staying with them
one night several armed members of the
KKK showed up in front of the house
dragged Obadiah out of the house and
beat him up for looking at a white woman
they then killed him right in front of
Frank with a shotgun blast To The Head
and the local sheriff made sure that the
men got away with murder if true then
this kind of traumatic event would
certainly have an effect on anybody
especially a small child but
investigators have failed to uncover
evidence to support Lucas's claim so
maybe it was an absolutely heinous
murder that went unpunished or maybe it
was something Frank Lucas made up as an
excuse for his crimes oh we can't really
tell but one thing is for sure this will
not be Lucas's last claim to Ghana more
than its fair share of doubts and
controversy anyway from that point on
Frank Lucas was an innocent child no
more the harsh realities of life for a
poor black family in the American South
during the Great Depression had hardened
him prematurely and he began doing
whatever was necessary to help out his
parents and younger siblings he started
out by sneaking into of farms to steal
eggs and chickens afterwards he
escalated to robbing drunks by awaiting
them to leave bars or brothels and then
whacking them over the head with a bat
violence quickly became not only routine
for Lucas but the default way that he
would solve his problems as a teenager
he found a regular job as a truck driver
for a pipe company but that went South
when the boss caught him sleeping with
his daughter Frank's solution oh is to
caution on the head with a lead pipe
steal his money and then set the
business on fire this was far more
extreme than any other crime that Lucas
had committed up to this point he knew
that something like this would not go
unanswered and that he needed to go
somewhere far far away so in the summer
of 1944 he boarded a Greyhound bus and
rode it all the way to the corner of
50th Street and 8th Avenue in New York
City he then got another city bus Which
took him to 114th Street in Harlem the
location
owerri would establish his criminal
Empire
Frank Lucas might have made it to Harlem
but he was penniless jobless and
homeless and did not know anyone who
could help him remedy that situation
therefore unsurprisingly he resumed his
unlawful ways his technique owes hardly
the work of a master criminal Lucas saw
somebody carrying money he would Wallop
them over the head with whatever was
handy Take the Money and Run it didn't
matter to him if it was a delivery man
or some two-bit gangster collecting
money for a numbers racket anyone it was
fair game as far as he was concerned by
the time he had enough stolen money to
rent a room and buy himself a gun Lucas
was a self-described menace to society
now that he was packing heat Lucas got
Brazen and started robbing places
instead of random people on the street
bars bodega's grocery stores clothing
shops he hit them all indiscriminately
but they all paled in comparison to
Frank's next Target a gambling Den known
as the big track it all started after
Lucas robbed a jeweler and made off with
some loose diamonds he didn't really
know anyone who could handle that kind
of merchandise but he was eventually
introduced to a gangster named Cool
Breeze who offered him 30 grand for the
Stones like it was loose change for most
other people in Harlem Cool Breeze was
the kind of guy they wanted to avoid and
if they couldn't they tried to stay on
his good side but as far as Lucas was
concerned he just saw him as a big fat
juicy Target by following Cool Breeze
around Lucas discovered the big track a
Gambling Hall in the basement of our
hotel where other gangsters with Deep
Pockets went to shoot craps and play
cards for big Stakes other robbers might
have considered the big track as as
impregnable as Fort Knox but Lucas was
the proverbial kid in the candy store
after going there a few times to case
the giant he made his way to the big
track one day armed with two guns and
had everyone lined up against the wall
and take their clothes off so they
wouldn't follow him out after he
absconded with their money most of the
men in there obeyed Lucas in stunned
silence more shocked than angry that
someone would have the audacity to Rob
them except for one guy named Fat Daddy
who mailed off at Lucas and got shot in
the ass for his troubles after the heist
Lucas assumed that he was the most
Wanted Man in Harlem but he continued
his activities as usual not really
caring whether he lived or died one
thing's for sure though he he never went
anywhere without a gun in his pocket but
for whatever reason the hit he assumed
would come never did something else did
happen though which had a tremendous
impact on Lucas's life as he was
introduced to the man who would help him
become the new Kingpin of Harlem
[Music]
as Lucas tells it one day was at
metten's pool room at 118th and 7th
Avenue a guy he knew only as Iceberg
read walked in flushed with cash looking
for Challengers willing to put up a
thousand dollars a game now as far as
Lucas knew ice pick red earned his name
by working as a killer for hire who was
willing to murder anyone for twenty five
thousand dollars his preferred method
was to simply walk up to his Target in
the strait and stab him in the chest
with an ice pick before running away
this didn't deserve Lucas who approached
ice pick and challenged him to a game
even though he only had three dollars in
his pocket red was about to go off on
Lucas when someone walked into the pool
hall he wore an expensive dark blue suit
with a red tie and a red lapel and made
everyone stand at attention in silence
even though it was only about five foot
nine and 160 pounds that man was Bumpy
Johnson and he owned the streets of
Harlem bumpy walked up to Lucas who was
still a kid at the time and asked him if
he can beat ice pick Luca said yes and
gave bumpy the order to rack the balls
fronting the money for him Lucas won the
pool game and every thing else according
to him was history afterward Johnson
took Lucas in his car and rode around to
everyone who had a grudge against him
Cool Breeze Fat Daddy every store owner
he ever robbed and made it clear that
the kid was with him now and that nobody
was allowed to touch him they all just
had to sit there with a smile on their
face and bear it after that Lucas became
Bumpy's right hand man and student at
the game spending years under his
learning as he was taught everything
there was to know about being a mob boss
until 1968 when Bumpy Johnson passed
away thus Paving the way for Frank Lucas
to take over that is the story according
to Frank not everyone agrees with it
though and other people in Johnson's
life including his own wife maim say
that Lucas greatly exaggerated the
mentor mentee relationship between him
and bumpy in fact Maeve Johnson even
said in her own book that bumpy actually
took another kid named a flash Walker
under his wing and that Lucas simply
took that relationship which he saw
firsthand and claimed it as his own in
his defense Luca said the bumpy kept
home life and business strictly separate
and that his wife was not aware of most
things he was involved with but
unfortunately for him the timeline works
against him as well the one thing we do
note for certain was that Bumpy Johnson
enjoyed an 11-year forced vacation at
the luxurious and Scenic Alcatraz
Federal Penitentiary on a drug
conspiracy charge between 1952 and 1963.
what happened during this time all we
can't say because Lucas glosses over
this tiny detail in his biography and
only makes a few quick references
instead he prefers to jump ahead to the
late 1960s recalling the event where
bumpy allegedly died in his arms at
wells's restaurants of heart failure
whatever the truth might have been the
reality was that Bumpy Johnson was dead
and Frank Lucas always ready to take
over Harlem
Frank Lucas had no problem admitting
that he was a completely different man
from Bumpy Johnson he saw bumpy as a
generous neighborhood Hustler who wanted
to share the wealth and look after the
small businesses and Mum and pop stores
in Harlem Lucas on the other hand fully
intended to give in to his greed and
keep everything for himself he saw his
operation as a lot grander than the
small time numbers and protection
rackets that were common in Harlem back
then drugs or the real money and Lucas
already had an ambitious plan in mind
ever since he worked for bumpy Lucas got
the idea of traveling to Southeast Asia
and buying heroin Straight From the
Source thus eliminating the middleman
and maximizing their profits back then
the area where Thailand wow and Myanmar
met known as The Golden Triangle was the
biggest opium producer in the world
however when he suggested this to his
boss bumpy said no and that was the end
of the discussion but now the bumpy
wasn't around anymore the plan was back
on the table and Lucas had no intention
of waiting a few days after Johnson's
funeral Frank was on a flight to
Thailand Lucas did not have any
connections in Asia but he knew that if
he followed the trail of drunkies long
enough eventually they would lead him to
the source Bangkok was teaming with
American GI so Lucas frequented some
Soldier bars and found plenty of
servicemen willing to sell him heroin
but only a key here and two keys there
none of them could provide him with dope
on the scale that he envisioned plus
they were all getting their drugs from
somebody else and the whole point of
Lucas's plan was to buy straight from
the source and eliminate all the
middlemen eventually work got around
that Lucas was looking to buy and the
source came to him it was a Chinese man
dressed in a nice suit riding around in
a white rolls-roy ass whom Lucas only
referred to as 007 because he thought he
looked like the Asian James Bond the two
of them quickly formed a profitable
relationship Lucas had the money and 007
had all the heroin that he could ever
want being delivered straight from
hidden jungles inside Golden Triangle
the dealer even had a way of smuggling
the drugs out of the country and into
the United States on military planes he
introduced Frank Lucas to U.S army
Master Sergeant Ike Atkinson better
known as sergeant smack together they
came up with the notorious cadaver
connection named after the fact that
Lucas smuggled drugs inside the coffins
of dead servicemen being repatriated to
the United States the way Lucas tells it
he brought Carpenter from North Carolina
to make his special coffin stating we
had him make up 28 copies of the
government coffins except oh we fixed
them up with false bottoms big enough to
load up with six maybe eight kilos it
had to be snug you couldn't have sliding
around Ike was very smart because he
made sure we used heavy guys as coffins
he didn't put them in those skinny guys
that was one smuggling run out of a few
dozen over the course of approximately
six years on another occasion Lucas
bragged that he smuggled 125 Keys aboard
the plane of U.S Secretary of State
Henry Kissinger by bribing a general 100
Grand to look the other way the story
about the cadaver connection comes from
Lucas himself in an interview and later
he reaffirmed it in his own bio just one
small problem though everyone else is
called BS on it the DEA said it was a
lie the federal judge who tried Lucas
said it was a lie and a researcher and
biographer called it the biggest hoax in
the history of the international drug
trade even Ike Atkinson good old
sergeant smack said it was not true in
fact Atkinson said a lot more than that
once again Frank Lucas was being accused
by somebody of taking their story and
claiming it as his own in order to make
himself look more impressive Sergeant
smack said that he was the one running
the international drug cartel and had
set up the operation before Lucas even
stepped foot in Thailand he was the one
who brought in the carpenter but he had
him build Hollow furniture with hidden
compartments to smuggle the drugs into
the United States not coffins and Lucas
was simply a buyer one of several and
nothing more we might not know what
exactly happened in Thailand but back in
Harlem there was no doubt that Frank
Lucas was making a killing both
figuratively and literally his product
which called Blue Magic was cut to 10 to
12 Purity which was twice as strong as
other competitors he could afford it
after all since he paid 4 thousand two
hundred dollars a key back in Thailand
which was worth at least 50 Grand in New
York but while this meant that Lucas had
the dopest dope on the street it also
brought a lot of deaths from overdoses
from addicts who were used to taking
much weaker drugs but Lucas had no
concerns about such matters he was too
busy counting his millions buying legit
businesses to launder his money and
rubbing shoulders or with celebs at
fancy restaurants and exclusive
nightclubs but we all know that the good
times don't last forever
the one big problem with living a lavish
lifestyle is that it tends to get you
noticed and that's not something you
always want in one notorious instance
Frank Lucas attended the 1971
championship boxing match between
Muhammad Ali and smoking Joe Frazier
wearing a 100
000 chinchilla fur coat and a matching
hat worth twenty five thousand dollars
given that the match was billed as the
fight of the century and was without a
doubt one of the most publicized
sporting events in history Lucas
attracted a fair bit of attention just
not from the people he expected even he
admitted that as far as the D.A was
concerned Lucas came to the fight as an
unknown and left it A Marked Man Blue
Magic was already known to the feds but
the man behind the dope was a mystery
well not anymore a task force consisting
of DEA and NYPD agents was assigned to
deal with Lucas it took them a few years
to build their case but in early 1975
they executed a raid on his home in
Teaneck New Jersey and arrested Frank
Lucas he and dozens of his associates
were indicted in the years that followed
and in 77 Frank himself was sentenced to
70 years total for one state term and
one Federal but curiously enough he was
released on parole after serving only
five years how did that happen well it's
obvious he became a government informant
and his information led to the arrests
of dozens of Associates and corrupt
officials just don't expect him to ever
admit it even in his tell-all interview
he refused to discuss the BS about being
buddy buddy with the cops and insisted
that he never testified against anyone
in court surely all those decades taken
off his sentence must have been just
because people liked him so much anyway
in 1982 Frank Lucas was a free man again
but the government had confiscated all
of his ill-gotten gains that was a bit
of Bill to swallow for an extravagant
man who got used to spending money like
it had an expiration date to nobody's
surprise Lucas got back to the thing
that he did best selling drugs however
his career Renaissance did not last long
he was arrested again in 1984 and got
another seven years in prison on new
drug charges this time he served the
entire sentence before being released
again in 1991. this part of his life is
a mystery that even Lucas glossed over
in his own autobiography probably
because it didn't make for an
interesting read from a man who beat
fact or fiction liked to present his
life story as the most thrilling
adventure ever seen he insisted that he
went straight and laid low claiming that
he made some legit money by using his
old connections to organize fundraisers
for an oil business but realistically
Frank Luke is the drug kingpin was gone
for good and it wasn't until 2000 that
Frank Lucas the media celeb emerged it
all started with his tell-all interview
with New York Magazine after that
Hollywood came and knocking at his door
wanting to turn his story into a movie
this led to the 2007 Ridley Scott crime
film American Gangster where Frank Lucas
was not only played by Denzel Washington
but the real Lucas got to hang around
the set and serve as a consultant the
movie was described by the federal judge
who tried Frank Lucas as one percent
reality and 99 Hollywood and he too
proclaimed Ike Atkinson to be the true
head of the heroine smuggling ring
between New York and the Golden Triangle
but frankly because it made little
difference his Newfound Fame ensured
that he spent his final years as a minor
celebrity giving interviews and making
appearances at conventions before dying
on May the 30th 2019 at the age of 88.
Frank Lucas's story was out there for
everyone to see truth or not it was the
way he wanted it to be told as the
criminal mastermind who served first as
a protege of the infamous Bumpy Johnson
and then took over the streets of Harlem
as his most powerful Kingpin
[Music]